[Musique]
valéry giscard d'estaing est décédé
mercredi des suites de lakovic 19 à
l'âge de 94 ans un président réformateur
au pouvoir entre 1974 et 1981 il a
notamment instauré la majorité à 18 ans
légaliser les vg ou encore le divorce
par consentement mutuel le premier
ministre jean castex s'est rendu à
trappes dans l'entreprise connaît un
leader dans le secteur des ascenseurs
objectif aller à la rencontre des jeunes
sans formation pour promouvoir le plan
un jeune une solution une nouvelle
opération de dépistage massif a pris
place au vélodrome nationale des tests
antigénique accessible à tous pour
lutter contre la copie de 19
l'accès était sur rendez vous via
l'application d'octo libre 2000 tests
devaient être réalisés
la première étape d'allègement des
mesures du confinement a été actionnée
les commerces dits non essentiels ont
rouvert leurs portes
l'activité physique est désormais
autorisée dans un rayon de 20 km pour
une durée maximale de trois heures coup
d'envoi du projet rer vélo un réseau de
650 km de pistes cyclables en
ile-de-france pour circuler en toute
sécurité
le projet prévoit la réalisation de neuf
lignes dont 5 devrait être mise en
service d'ici 2025
coût total 500 millions d'euros
[Musique]
pas